nous voici donc réunis pour une
conférence sur alors sur précisément le
livre de philidor en vidant je voulais
vous parler bien sûr aussi de philidor
le joueur un petit peu mais c'est pas le
thème de la conférence le thème c'est
plutôt son livre donc analyse du jeu
d'échecs dont on va parler alors pour
pour calais il faut que je cherchais
aussi une information voilà ici je vous
ai préparé un petit graphique alors
c'est le même que j'ai présentées pour
ceux qui étaient là sur la conférence
pour sur wii lopez c'est un graphique
historique qui vous présente philidor
dans la trame de l'histoire des grands
joueurs d'échecs se reprend c'est assez
important parce qu'on n'a pas forcément
une bonne idée donc ici c'est un
histogramme qui part de 1450 pourquoi
1450 c'est l'invention de l'imprimerie
en europe
que tu aimes faire donc c'est important
puisque le premier livre imprimé au sens
imprimerie moderne au sens mécanique
c'est 1497 pour le premier livre d'échec
c'est lou sénat avec le fameux lucena
qui avait inventé la manoeuvre le bon de
lui sénat dans les finales de tours et
puis donc il va jusqu'en 1900 qui est un
peu le début des échecs moderne avec le
premier champion du monde
steinitz alors donc on a lu sénat qui
arrive
à la fin du xvième d'air la fin du xvème
début 16e le sénat qui a écrit donc ce
premier livre imprimé
ensuite on a dernier anouk et un joueur
portugais alors tout le sénat c'est un
prêtre espagnol
un prêtre espagnol damiano c'était un
portier qui a écrit son livre donc début
début 16e les les rectangles verts et
rouges sont la durée de la vie des
joueurs d'accord c'est la durée de la
vie des joueurs et quand on passe du
vert au rouge c'est le moment pile où le
joueur a écrit son livre
voilà donc ça vous montre l'endroit dans
la vie des joueurs où ils ont écrit leur
livre important donc damiano alors
damiano c'est intéressant à connaître
celui qui a inventé le gambit de damiano
alors le gambit damiano si vous
connaissez pas je vous donne les coups
puis vous vérifierez sur un échiquier
ce4 cinq cavaliers f4f 6 on vous a vu
six avec les noirs et qu'elle allait
prendre 5 sacrifie le cavalier sur cinq
est en fait c'est très bon pour les
blancs mais c'est pas si clair que ça si
on joue bien c'est à dire que y avant
l'ouverture à creuser c'est ce qu'avait
fait damiano et ensuite c'est ce qu'a
fait le ru lopez luis lopez qui arrive
après va passer un quart de son livre a
réfuté dernier nous en fait
ou en tout cas améliorer ses variantes
parce qu'il réussit pas tout il dit
qu'il ya des quand même des choses
bonnes mais il va quand même pas mal
passé pas mal de temps pour réfuter pas
mal de choses que damien nous avait dit
dans son livre on est sur les premiers
grands théoriciens et rui lopez est
considéré encore aujourd'hui et
particulièrement dans les espagnols
sacrés espagnols comme évidemment le
comme le père de la théorie donc voilà
il est je pense à juste titre c'est le
premier qui va faire une revue
exhaustive de tous les débuts de partie
on aura même une début un début
scandinave dans la rue lopez alors qu'à
l'époque il joue surtout un des gants
vie du roi je passe c'était le sujet de
la conférence de l'est
et donc alors après on a que le fameux
gréco vous avez entendu parler sans
doute gréco fameux joueur italien qui a
beaucoup joué en europe 1 se déplace en
faisant des simultanée des exhibitions
ils essaient de vivre de cette activité
là et il avait écrit son livre je crois
savoir mais je sais ça reste à vérifier
je le dis de mémoire qu'il a fait éditer
son livre la première fois en france
voilà il était en france à ce moment-là
déplacement il faisait simultanée et il
ya un trou à ce moment là parce que
grégoire jeunes y meurt il a quelques
vingt ans il meurt à ces jeunes s'est
fait détrousser en plus d'ailleurs
l'argent qu'il avait gagné dans les
exhibitions a disparu il s'est fait
détrousser
il est mort et il ya un trou voyez entre
les débuts des années 1600 jusqu'à
legrand jusqu'au grand fils d'or leur
vie d'avant il ya quand même quelques
joueurs il ya quand même des anglais qui
commence à écrire des livres en ce
moment là ça commence à foisonner les
bouquins mais ya pas de très grands
joueurs on a au filet d'eau rare il ya
un syrien qui à l'ombre qui qui fait qui
fait beaucoup parler de lui qui est très
fort qui est un très fort pouvoir qui
s'appelle stamm à philips ta main et
bien finie d'or alors que la veille
trois ans parce qu'il est né en 1726 il
ya pas moins de trois ans quand ils
rentrent constat massa d'être en 1745
donc soit deux ans avant de l'écrire son
niveau il doit avoir 21 ans ou 46 soit
encore recette je sais plus d'avoir 21
ans quand il rencontre sa main et il
écrase stamm à à londres par le score de
7 à 3 alors cela c'est la grande
bisbilles entre les anglais et les
français pour savoir qui dit a les
meilleurs joueurs entre le club de
londres et le fameux
café de la régence à paris philidor on
peut pas séparer philidor du café la
région s'enfonce avoir fini donc c'est
l'élève de d'un autre joueur à ses
célèbres on va avoir laissé un math
célèbre qui est le fameux le gall le
gall qui était donc aussi donc un bon
joueur qui a un peu fort mais philidor
donc fini des musiciens ni n'est donc en
1726 il fait partie d'une longue lignée
de musiciens les philidor donc la
famille des philidor qui est au service
du roi de france depuis plusieurs
générations pour faire de la musique
pour jouer de la musique pour en
composer et c'est donc fini dans et déjà
été un grand musicien
c'est même le très grand musicien parce
qu'aujourd'hui encore on a des
orchestres qui enregistre du philidor
c'est pas donné à tous les musiciens
d'avoir encore aujourd'hui il orchestre
qui qui choisissent d'enregistrer des
musiques à moi j'ai donc le dernier cd
de filles d'orgelet facile à trouver
mais on le trouve
voilà vous pouvez trouver le laisser pas
mal c'est vrai que c'est de la musique
du xviiie et c'est c'est tout à fait c
était déjà c'était un grand musicien est
semble-t-il ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
il s'est mis à jouer aux échecs c'est
que avec sa troupe de musiciens entre
les présentations pas s ennuyer un petit
peu ce qu'ils n'avaient pas passé leur
langue leur temps à répéter
donc il fallait qu'ils aient une
activité et donc plusieurs qui jouent
aux cartes mais non il fut dissous sont
mis à jouer aux échecs
et donc voilà fini dans est devenu assez
rapidement le plus grand joueur du café
la référence est ensuite donc à londres
il a fait ses armes il s'est fait
connaître en battant stamm à 7 à 3 et
donc laisser les anglais qui l'ont
proposé 2
de faire ce livre son premier livre donc
il le fait en 1749 donc il a 23 ans
donc en deux ans après le match contre
slama et donc c'est ce fameux analyse du
jeu d'échecs alors la première édition
du livre en 1749 comporte quelque chose
comme 11 parties commentées et une
finale et une finale qui va devenir
fameuse puisqu'elle comporte une
position de philidor une position qui
tardent aussi en a plusieurs qui est
celle de la position de philidor de la
finale touré fou contre tours alors
peut-être vous ne savez pas ce que ça
dépend du niveau qu'on a aux échecs mais
la finale tour il faut contre tours 1
figurez vous qu'elle est très difficile
à défendre et qui amène donc des
positions où elle est gagnante
ce qui paraît extrêmement étonnant
lorsqu on se dit on a juste un fou de
plus que l'on peut gagner ça eh bien on
peut la gagner et c'est fini d'or le
premier qui va démontrer est expliqué
dans son livre la position à partir de
laquelle on peut gagner cette finale
alors évidemment on n'est pas obligé non
plus d'entrer dans cette position là
mais si on se trouve dans cette position
dont on peut pas empêcher le mat
voilà faut être précis mais je vais vous
quand même vous donner une petite
anecdote vous montre à quel point c'est
pas facile à défendre et à quel point
aussi cette position de philidor et est
cruciale il ya eu un blitz or si un
blitz mais sur ce qu'on parle partie
lendemain quand même on a eu un blitz
carsen ziegler en 2010 je crois ont
peut-être un peu avant qui est
disponible sur internet vous qu'on peut
le trouver il est référencé sur la page
internet qui parle du livre de philidor
gelé me justement en titre d'exemple ou
carsen arrive à battre ce vide l'air
dans une finale touré fou contre tours
et une fille naturelle contre tours
normale c'est-à-dire au départ n'est pas
du tout dans la position de philidor
sidler et c'est très très dur à défendre
car c'est la rivale poussé dans la
position de philidor et on faire à la
fin ils arrivent à lui planter le mag
forces et ses 1 300 ans après où 200 250
ans après car celle des montres que
fille dans avait raison
donc pour avoir trouvé ça à l'époque
sans ordinateur fallait comme se lever
tôt voilà donc ça cette finale donc elle
apparaît en 1849 alors ce livre il a une
histoire parce qu'il n'est pas sa seule
édition
il va l'enrichir on va lui demander de
refaire une deuxième édition donc il ya
une deuxième édition qui apparaît en
1777 d'accord alors qui dit dormeur en
1795 donc mais encore il est encore en
bonne forme et donc 1,77
alors il reprend bien sûr les parties de
la première édition c'est une continuité
mais il va quand même corriger quelques
points il va rajouter quelques variantes
donc c'est quand même pas le même livre
il est quand même dû beaucoup plus gros
c'est vraiment l'édition définitive 1777
il va rajouter trois parties commentées
donc on en est à 13 ou 14 et enfin il va
donc enrichir les finales puisqu'il va
ou offrir toutes les finales de base car
je vais même vous le lire
donc vous sachiez de quoi il s'agit
c'est très important de retourner à mon
avis parce que ça fait du philidor un
manuel complet un débutant peut tout à
fait à prendre le jeu avec le manuel du
fil d'or puisqu'il aura toutes les
finales de base ce qui est essentiel
plus toutes les parties commentées de
philidor avec donne tous les conseils et
je dirais fondamentaux à connaître donc
on peut démarrer avec le fil d'or ce qui
passe forcément qu avec le wii lopez
puisqu'il explique pas les maths
ils vont leur eu le plaisir de tous les
ouvertures dont je vais vous dire quand
même voilà tous les matchs l'ia vous
compreniez bien qui a tout donc le
fameux la tour est fou contre tours très
important en général c'est des joueurs
là c'est bon niveau qui savent qu'ils
savent faire ce match on est à dix
joueurs à 2000 2100 peut-être 2200 mais
même parmi des joueurs 2002 mills en
2002 ça y'en a qui le connaissent pas
pas facile de savoir planter ce matin
pourtant ça arrive souvent mais j'ai vu
souvent à paris dans des tournois rapide
des grands maîtres de type
f par exemple je les vis de 2,3 fois
gagner des parties avec cette finale là
et les joueurs en face qui essaye de
tenir mais non c'est très étonnant quand
on sait pas que ça gagne on se dit
comment c'est possible avec juste un sou
de plus qu'on arrive à gagner le lac du
fouillis de cavaliers important matteo
rixe et fille dort encore une fois le
premier qui donne la méthode complète
allant données annonce est là dans cette
position on a un mât de forcer en
dix-neuf couvre pas mal matsui cavaliers
pas facile à planter il arrive très
souvent il est très rare et la réunion
est par contre le connaître je pense ça
améliore sa une bonne compréhension du
maniement de ces pièces mineurs là qui
ont besoin d'être complémentaire pour
être efficace donc en général mais le
cavalier sous la couleur du fou comme ça
ils contrôlent les cases opposé ainsi il
est sûr qu'à ce nom et contre les cases
blanches et donc si on a le foot 15 n 3
la fois les cases blanches avec
lecavalier est quasiment avec le front
et puis bien sûr il ya le roi qui vient
en plus et des voix l'amap du fait du
cavalier là aussi peu de joueurs sable
faire on a des grands maîtres qui ont du
mal à le planter ça arrive qui se
hasarde dans cette position aussi et
c'est pas toujours facile
alors il ya aussi tous reppion
contrefous alors là de manière étonnante
philidor il va montrer qu'il ya une
position qui semble t-il vous laisse je
voulais ce travail est la chose qui
semble qu'ici on pousse trop le pion
trop vite bien on finit par ne pas
gagner quoi alors qu'on se dit que tout
répond ben tanfous ça de gagner à tous
les coups mais ça paraît si clair si on
regarde la méthode de philidor le match
de la tour seul bon sens général
koné le match de dand et tour fadam
contre touré pions pas facile ça alors
ça m'a pas toujours ça dépend où les
pions comme il explique qu'on peut faire
nul mais il faut pas que le pion et
bouger de là s'arranger de départ il
faut qu'il soit encore sur sa rangée
initial on ne peut pas je vais pas vous
détailler
on verra quelques partis et quelques
conseils tout à l'heure mais je ne peux
pas cru le faire là mais juste pour vous
donner un panorama de ce qu'il fait on a
le madame contre tours classique aussi
qu'il faut connaître il expliqué touré
pure contre tours
alors voilà encore une finale très
célèbre et là une finale fréquentes tour
étions contre tours c'est très fréquent
dans l'open je suis sûr qu'elle a déjà
des dizaines et des dizaines qu'on a
déjà été joué depuis le début
touré pions contre tours alors il faut
savoir que là on a aussi une fameuse
position de philidor on a donc deux
tours est fou contre tours et on a tous
récurrentes ont toqué beaucoup plus
fréquentes on à la méthode exact en
ferme nul si on n'a que la tour pour pas
faire n'importe quoi c'est précis il
explique très bien ce qu'il faut faire
et donc si on sait comment on peut faire
nul en défense on sait ce qu'il faut
éviter de faire en attaque il faut pas
que l'adversaire obtiennent la position
de fizi dans donc ç'a permis de jouer
des deux côtés bien sûr mais faut la
connaître encore faut-il la connaître
cette cette finale voilà elle est
magnifiquement expliqué par fille dort
elle est vraiment super bon on a damé
pions contre dame d'un million contre
dame me rappelais pas si vous savez mais
quand le pion et sur ces sept ou f7 et
bien on peut faire nul parce qu'on met
le roi sont ainsi le curé sur ses sept
ans mais le mans 1 à 8
quand la dame fait échec et si la dame
prend le pion mais on n'est pas bon mais
ça donc philidor l'expliqué bien et il
explique que dans les autres cas on peut
gagner alors on l'a aussi dames contre
pion aux prennent aux dames donc c'est
un peu la même dame étions contre dame
parties nulles d'options seul or là
aussi roi epyon contre roanne
normalement le connaissez un des
premiers films première chose qu'on
apprend
voilà philidor vous explique comment
faire ça voyez donc s'adresse à la fois
aux débutants jusqu'aux grands joueurs
parce que quand il va donner conseil de
parti ça va être assez assez poussé un
on a cavaliers contre-pied auprès de
dames 1 à 2 points contre un et deux kg
ont séparé contre deux pions unis a
aussi donc des conseils généraux sur les
finales de pions et on a eu on a eu dans
ce tournoi une magnifique finale de deux
pions qui a été joué par jean françois
joly avant-hier et qu'il a gagné face à
adrien demuth une finale qui
théoriquement devait sans doute être nul
mais peut-être peut-être que j'enfonce
joly avait lu philidor elle est
forcément ça fait la différence
donc pour dire que même les grands
maîtres arrivent pas forcément à jouer
parfaitement une finale de pions c'est
pas des choses qui font négliger c'est
ce sont des finales très difficile et
qui arrivent de façon relativement
fréquentes
on vient donc avoir un exemple dans le
dans ce national alors sur le sur le
texte de sur le texte de philidor il ya
un peu de texte ou si je vais vous
donnez donnez quelques mois il ya une
préface à nous le dire ici que j'ai fait
moi qui fais quand tu fais 400 pages qui
donne un peu d indications sur
l'histoire du joueur j'ai mis dans le
livre donc réédité ici les deux préface
1 parce qu'il ya deux préface puisqu'il
ya 7749 et 10 777
donc forcément il en a écrit deux sont
très différentes celle de 17 149 est
beaucoup plus riche que celle de 1777
alors notamment il nous il nous cite
dans sa préface de 1749 que les îles un
peu le premier à avoir un peu expliqué
correctement je dirais la manière de
jouer parce qu'il nous dit par exemple
ici dans sa danse afin de préface il
revient je reviens à don pietro carrera
qui était un auteur italien qui selon
toute apparence a servi de modèle aux
calabrais et à d'autres auteurs
cependant ni lui ni aucun d'eux ne nous
ont donné malgré l'anc rendre prolixité
que des destructions m parfaite est
insuffisante pour former un bon joueur
ils se sont uniquement appliqué à ne
donner que des ouvertures de jeu donc
attention à ne pas se contenter des
toutes les ouvertures en échec
c'est ça qui nous explique et ensuite il
nous avons des soins dame étudier les
fins ça ne vous donne pas du tout une
indication sur les finales c'est un peu
fini dans le premier est vraiment à
traiter les finales on le dit pas assez
ça avant lui on n'explique pas les
finales c'est pourtant peut-être le plus
important pour bien comprendre comment
jouer aux échecs de sorte que le joueur
reste à peu près aussi embarrassé que si
lui été contraint s'il lutte était
contraint là c'est le style xviiie
imparfait du subjonctif là où plus que
parfait je sais pas je suis pas un grand
mais je suis pas le grammairien
théorique mais c'est quand même joli ci
lui été contraint de commencer la partie
sans instruction cuningham et bertin qui
sont deux auteurs anglais nous donne des
gambie fameux fameux gambie de cuisine
gamme de bertin que philidor va
détailler dans son livre des exemples
fini gamme et bertem d'ondés gambie
qu'ils font perdre ou gagner en faisant
mal jouer l'adversaire
il n'est pas tout ce qu'ils les
trouvaient leur compte dans une méthode
si facile
et peu laborieuse voyez ce moment que
deux comme l'ain il n'est pas douteux
qu'il n'ait trouvé leur compte dans une
méthode si facile et si peu laborieuse
mais aussi quelle utilité
un amateur peut-il tirer d'une
instruction semblables pas très
intéressant fait in fine est de montrer
des choses brillantes mais qui vous aide
pas à faire des parties d'échecs
donc j'ai connu des joueurs d'échecs qui
savait tout le pari le calabre et et
d'autres auteurs parker et qui après
avoir joué les quatre ou cinq premiers
coups ne savait plus où donner de la
tête
voyez il faut bien comprendre qu'ils
nous expliquent que là parce que c'est
très important c'est tout l'esprit de
son livre mais j'ose dire hardiment que
celui qui sera maître en usage les
règles que je donne ici ne sera jamais
dans le même cas je me suis gardé
d'imiter ses auteurs qui ne sachant
comment remplir leur feuille laison
farsi d'une quantité de jeux ranger mais
plutôt au jeu d'enfant parce que leur
situation ne se rencontreront pas une
fois en mille ans c'est gonflé quand
même pour montrer les fin de partie qui
n'aboutissent à rien les à moteur les
amateurs pardon se contentent orange
espère de leur avoir donné un maudit
comme des bêtes bonhomme c'est du latin
donc qui veut dire modeste et bon qui
est utile instructif et qui peut se
contenter qui peut se rencontrer dans
toutes les parties jeu mais je mets même
tous les maths excepté celui du fou de
la tour contre le tour adverse alors ça
c'est comme celle à la préface de 49 il
dit que là il n'a pas il avait parmi les
autres matches à part celui là c'est pas
le cas dans celle de 1777
alors écoutez bien ce passage la très
important c'est même ce qu'on a retenu
de philidor à tort parce que devient on
sait qu'une partie mais c'est quand même
important
mon but principal est de me rende
recommande recommandable par une
nouveauté dont personne ne s'est avisé
ou peut-être n'a été capable si celle de
bien jouer les pions ils sont l'âme des
échecs on va dire on dit souvent fille
dora dit les pions solesmes du jeu
d'échecs n'est pas exactement la phrase
1 la phrase c'est ça veut dire la même
chose mais comme je vous le dis une
nouveauté dans personnes et sert visée
ou peut-être moins été capable c'est
celle de bien jouer les pions de points
ils sont l'âme des échecs
ce sont eux uniquement qui forment
l'attaqué la défense et de leurs bons ou
mauvais arrangement dépend entièrement
le gain ou la perte de la partie un
joueur qui ne s'est pas même en jouant
bien pions la raison pour laquelle il le
joue est à comparer un général qui a
beaucoup de pratique et peu de théorie
il y va quand même
voilà êtes en train de vous dire que
vous savez pas joué que lui et vous
explique m voilà alors sur le prophète
1717 est beaucoup plus courte et donc il
ya peu d'informations par rapport à ces
deux 49 qui est quand même plus riches
alors il donne des informations quand
même historique intéressante au début il
nous dit plusieurs savants ont publié
leurs recherches sur l'origine du jeu
d'échecs je ne déciderai point de leur
conformité avec les la troupe coulis de
l'ancien grand mall of goo goo lee
c'était un jeu dans chrome 1 rue lopez
en parle beaucoup dans son livre
justement alors lui dit qu'il discutera
pas de si c'est conforme au peloton
coulis n'en sais rien le latron
coulisses où je jouais déjà sur 64 cases
en fait 8 x 8
d'accord mais semble-t-il l'on mange pas
un expert du lit du jeu mais je me suis
renseigné comme un peu j'ai regardé ce
qui induit lopez en attaque bien sûr
j'ai regardé on à diane il existe des
halles à tripoli
de l'autre une poulie dans certains
musées on en a retrouvé donc il ya bien
64 cases mais semble-t-il les pions sont
à peu près tous les mêmes c'est à dire
qu'on a des pions noirs et des pions
blancs et le jeu serait plutôt une prise
en sautant par dessus les pièces donc ça
ressemble quand même plus au jeu de
dames puissent contrôler dame vous savez
en sautant par dessus les pions de dames
donc mais le jeu de dames moderne c'est
c'est 10 x 10 en termes de cases c'est
pas mille fois huit
donc il faut bien tenir sans tête aussi
donc il est possible en tout cas que la
troupe bruits était influencé le
développement du jeu voilà en tout cas
il en parle mais sans dire que en dix
ans qui se prononcera pas il dit que les
chinois jouent aux échecs mais leur jeu
ne ressemble en rien aux nôtres donc ils
connaissaient déjà à l'époque le jeu
d'échecs chinois
c'est intéressant ça ni par la mare des
pions ni par la puissance des pièces les
arabes on introduit vraisemblablement ce
jeu en europe donc sans doute via
l'espagne
bien sûr puisque vous savez que
l'espagne était sous domination arabe
entre l'an 800 à peu près 1492 ya
quasiment sept siècles d'occupation et
rue lopez en parle abondamment bien sûr
donc les arabes ont introduit
vraisemblement se joue en europe et
leurs sauteurs on attribue l'invention
aux indiens c'est ce qu'on a retenu plus
ou moins aujourd'hui vous savez avec le
l'idée du chat tueur en ga en inde etc
donc il le dit mais bon il en sait pas
trop quoi c'est juste une annonce mais
ils donnent pas de source
certaines donc ça reste quand même un
peu
un peu incertain voilà donc voilà pour
vous voyez la partie textile au départ
est assez courte comparée alors au livre
de riz lopez qui nous lie à un tiers du
livre 1 quasiment qui fait description
des pièces histoire du jeu et c'est très
court en terme de prêts façon n'est sur
quelques pages donc le livre quand même
un livre essentiellement échiquéen
quasiment pas d'histoire ou très peu et
relativement peu de généralités au début
donc il ya beaucoup de contenu et chiker
alors donc si vous voulez bien on va
regarder un petit peu une des parties
que nous propose philidor pour
simplement peut-être la première voilà
et puis peut être après on regardera une
ou deux finales aussi comme ça on va
voir le style de l'auteur sait le mieux
aux deux premières parties allant dit
non quand même avant de rentrer dans
cette première partie pour que vous
compreniez bien le problème de d'avoir
un livre aussi ancien quand j'ai lu ce
livre mais surya pas écrit un e 4 ou 5
il ya écrit les blancs jouent le pion du
roi sur la quatrième classe durant ces
longs roux et les noirs il peut écrire
les noir vous de même où le noir joue le
pion du roi sur la 4e case du roi donc
attention pascal catherine ducasse du
roi ça dépend du côté où je suis aussi
c'est pas la même case
donc si vous avez oublié qu'ils jouent
d'ailleurs dans le texte si vous savez
plus c'est le blanc le noir est bien le
coup ne vous dis pas la couleur
il va quand il va jouer cavalier en f3
il va dire le cavalier du roi paix
religieuse est loin à l'opposé c'est le
cas et de la dame le kali droit va sur
la troisième case du fou du roi
donc ça c'est le coup moderne cavalli
gien un f3 d'accord donc c'est un peu
long pour dire que les gf3 ça marche
mais c'est long donc quand vous
traduisez arrive comme ça vous vous
cogner ça dans tous le libre alors c'est
facile ceci dit la l'écriture est facile
puisque c'est plus court
kbj un g3 c'est beaucoup plus pour moi
j'ai traduit tout ça maintenant je vais
pas laisser ce texte là parce que ça le
rendrait pas disponibles ce que j'ai
essayé de faire en rééditant le fils
dormait sur ces deux lots rendre de
manière de manière moderne donc je vais
montrer ici à la caméra d'ailleurs un
petit peu vous allez avoir une idée je
sais pas s'ils voient là vous voyez les
coups voilà contenu si voilà c'est un
manuel de tout à fait moderne voilà
alors il ya il ya aussi le fait que j'ai
rajouté un échiquier de manière assez
assez fréquentes il ya un échiquier
environ tous les quatre à cinq coups ou
comment on peut lire le livre sans
échiquier ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas parce que non si vous avez que des
coups bas sont efficaces et du rhin
alors que là bas vous pouvez le lire
dans le train normalement le livre tout
seul suffi puisqu'il ya suffisamment
échiquier transmis tous les 4 5 ou pour
vous permettre d'avoir relativement peu
d'effort mental à faire pour visualiser
les coûts intermédiaires à jouer voilà
donc pouvoir regarder cette première
partie méthode philidor vous allez voir
comment ça se passe alors le 4e 5 pouces
et quatre pouces et 5
ces trois donc beaucoup de parties avec
avec ses trois dans le philidor voyez
donc c'est un début qui je dois encore
un alors aujourd'hui à des coûts moderne
plus pratiqué mais mais celui là est
tout à fait correct cavaliers le 6 et
bien sûr on joue ces trois pour jouer
des quatre alors tout de suite un
commentaire de fil à un gros coup de
commentaires
c'est tout l'intérêt du livre c'est pas
des séries coup à apprendre c'est pas du
tout le but il vous l'a dit dès
l'ouverture
ils essaient de vous donner des conseils
et vous essayez de faire comprendre des
principes généraux le pion des avances
de deux cases pour deux raisons la
première afin d'empêcher le fou c'est 5
de viser le pion f2 d'accord je vous
rappelle qu'il n'a pas écrit ça du tout
moi jettera
il aurait dit alors j'ai pas le texte
original sous les yeux mais il vous a
dit la première afin d'empêcher le fou
sur la 4e case du roi noir du fou du roi
de 1 an pardon le fou sur la 4e case du
fou de la dame noire de viser le pion du
fou du roi
c'est pénible c'est quand même plus quoi
dire le fossé 5 de viser la casse et 2 1
voilà il ya des traductions à chaque
fois que ces descriptif
je suis revenu en algérie c'est quand
même beaucoup plus facile à lire donc le
pion dr ross de deux cases pour deux
raisons la première afin d'empêcher le
faux 6,5 de viser le pion f2 pour une
attaque contre le roi la seconde porte
et pour porter la force des pions vers
le centre de l'échiquier porter la force
des pions vers le centre de l'échiquier
donc la notion du centre
la notion de bloquer l'attaqué d'un fou
sur son roi ou sur le pion sur un pion
je dirais sensible le pion f2 ou tu
révises est sans détour sensible voilà
donc ici on continue la partie
maintenant je prends des quatre s'éprend
des 4 et là encore en commentaire au
figuré il est il et il n'est pas avare 1
lorsque vous vous trouvez dans la
situation présente à savoir avec deux
cures de front donc on voit bien ici le
pion des 4 et 4 sont des pions qu'on dit
qu'on peut appeler deux feront
effectivement il faut bien se garder
d'en pousser
aucun des deux il faut se garder de les
pousser pas mal sa garde et de pousser
aucun des deux avant que votre
adversaire ne vous propose d'échanger
l'un contre l'autre
donc par exemple que l'adversaire
propose plus tard de vous des cinq
nations
nous proposer des cinq on pousserait à 5
par exemple mais tant qu'ils ne
proposent pas en touche pas nos pions
c'est ça qui me dit ce que vous
éviterait à l'ordre si l'adversaire vous
justement proposé un échange ce que vous
éviterez alors en poussant plus avant le
furent attaqués voilà donc si des cinq
plus tard dans la partie alors un
scalable 5 mais pas avant si vous jouer
des scènes trop tôt et bien l'adversaire
pourra jouer des six pour attaquer votre
chaîne de pions voilà alors si vous
regardez il faut garder la souplesse en
fait de votre votre chaîne de fin de
votre groupement de pions de bouquins
qu'il appelle de front voilà le conseil
des fidèles donc ici les noirs jouent
sous les 6 alors si au lieu de se
retirer mais on se dit mais pourquoi pas
fous les quatre échecs bombay vous dit
vous explique quand même si au lieu de
se retirer ce fou d'un échec il faut
couvrir du fou on pourrait couvrir par
le phocéen un des deux d'accord et si
les noirs prennent ce fou il faut
reprendre du cavalier qui parce moyenne
défend le pion de 4 dans la sienne
édition donc dans l'édition de 749 donc
puisqu'on est dans celle la dernière
édition dans l'édition complète dans la
sienne édition j'avais cru que je
pouvais ne pas faire toujours joué le
coup juste pour avoir l'occasion de
donner des exemples fréquents sur la
manière de bien jouer les pions voilà
qu'est ce qui nous explique ici c'est
que je joue pas forcément toujours les
coups juste il essaie de vous expliquer
des conseils et des méthodes aux échecs
dont qui joue aussi quelquefois des
coûts qui sont des mauvais coups mais
comme ça que vous explique comment en
profiter
donc c'est manuel pratique aussi voilà
c'est pas manuel théorie qui vous donne
que les bons coups il vous donne des
mauvais coups pour savoir quoi faire
contre les mauvais coups et pour vous
éviter d'en faire aussi
on n'est pas du tout dans une
l'iran qui cherche à faire de la théorie
d'accord c'est important à comprendre
parce que beaucoup de livres aujourd'hui
c'est essaye de vous donner des suites
théorique parfaite avec tous les coups
toutes les variantes etc
c'est pas le but là le but c'est plutôt
de comprendre les grands principes à
l'aide de partis type où il ya des
erreurs bien sûr mais c'est fait pour
voilà de manière à bien comprendre
comment profiter justement cavale et c3
normal ici donc on défend le pion aux
quatre qui étaient attaqués et la petit
roquet est maintenant cavalier
j'ai un peu de vous alors il me dit il
faut se garder de jouer ce cavalier en
f3 ça c'est intéressant
il faut se garder de jouer ce client est
roi avant que le pion f2 n'ait été
poussée de deux cases il a envie de
jouer à quatre en fait voilà parce
qu'autrement le cavalier empêcherait sa
marche évident si on pouvait lire
tremblez un bloc le pion les noirs sur
ce coup pour reprendre le quai henri iv
des blancs et pousser ensuite le tube 17
ans des 5 ce qui romprait le ce qui
romprait le centre d'aidé blanquefort
une rupture
oui donc ce qui nous dit ici aussi c'est
que sur sur cavaliers f3 ou même dans la
position d'ailleurs ici on peut
envisager avec les membres de faire que
la vallée 34 d'accord calais prend 24
cavalli prend 1,4 et les noirs jouent
des 5
on récupère soit le fou ces quatre soit
le cac valeo 4 et on a cassé un petit
peu le centre blanc c'est envisageable
d'accord alors ici les noirs choisissez
de jouer plutôt des six c6 est fou
détroit le fou se retire pour ne pas
être attaqué par le pion des averses
on évite maintenant cette manoeuvre des
cinq langues
parce qu'alors les blancs seront
contraints de prendre le pont des sables
obtient 4 ce qui séparerait leurs pions
oui si on si on évite pas des cinq on
sera obligé de prendre des 5 avec le
pion eux et on aurait un pion dès qu'ils
seraient séparés des autres c'est à dire
en furie
donc nous explique attention un pion
isolé c'est quand même délicat
donc il vaut mieux éviter donc fou des
trois c'est fait pour éviter de séparer
nos pions comme ça les pions des 4e
quatre sont encore groupé avec les pions
f2 j'ai 2 h 2 on a une seule un seul
groupement de deux pions donc ici
continuer la partie des cinq peu cinq
cavaliers 8 fouet 3 et la m6 m6 ça
pourquoi m6 les noirs ou ce pion
commentaires de filles dans les donjons
ce pion pour faire une ouverture à leur
tour parce qu'on va ouvrir la colonne f
et cela est fort c'est que ce soit eux
qui prennent ou bien les blancs que ce
soit les blancs qui prennent ou ensuite
les noirs l'ouverture la colonne s ne
peut pas être évité voilà l'idée de ce
coup car souvent on dit qu'il faut pas
faut pas jouer les pions le pion f
ça peut affaiblir le roi etc mais là ils
tiennent bien le centre aussi bien c'est
à dire qu'on a baissé de ses six des
cinq qui tiennent bien le sens donc ya
pas de grands risques d'échec sur la
diagonale à 2 j'évite donc l'ouverture
des lignes et les justifier
même s'il ne dit pas ça se peut se
comprendre dam des deux il nous dit il
ne faut pas prendre le pion qui est
offert parce qu'alors il n'y aurait plus
de pions sur la colonne où on aurait
plus de le pion veut bien sûr si on
prenait alors qu en le laissant prendre
en laissant les noirs prendre il sera
remplacé par le pont des 4 et sera
ensuite soutenu par f4 ses deux pions
liés ensemble doivent produire le gain
de la partie
alors il vous dit que c'est les pions
sncf 4 une fois qu'on a joué f4 doivent
produire le gain de la partie pour lui
c'est un avantage un avantage d'être
c'est vrai que le pion aux cinq là il
est quasiment passé maintenant s'il est
soutenu par quatre on a en a aussi qui
ont passé on a un bond qui ont central
passé c'est vrai que ça peut
considéré comme un comme un avantage
pour lui carrément noghin f-35 les lois
reprennent le pion poursuivre le projet
de faire place à leur tour dé prendre 5
est maintenant faut 6 voilà faut 6 alors
vos commentaires ici les noirs jeu ce
fou pour pouvoir ensuite pour pouvoir
pousser ensuite le pion sait on veut
ensuite pouvoir pousser le pion c'est
pourquoi je vous aussi ce quel rapport
bien évidemment là on voit qu'on défend
le pion de d5 parce que si on jouait le
pion c'est trop tôt imaginez que le coup
d'avant le fou est encore assez vite on
joue le pion c5 dans ce cas là le pion
des 5es emprise vous pourrez faire
cavalier prendre des 5
parce que si si dame prend il ya la
manoeuvre classique l'attention fou
détroit après cet échec au roi le roi
est obligé de prendre et la dame est
perdu donc faut aussi ce pour jouer ces
oui ah oui très bien jouer et oui tout à
fait alors bd 400m idée alors ceci dit
oui je prends des quatre avec cavaliers
2 prend des 4 imaginons que vous faut
aussi des quatre cavaliers aux deux
prend des quatre fous prend fou prend et
si dame prend même manoeuvre fou prend à
cet échec
donc c'est la même idée alors est ce
qu'il nous en pas le dit pas mais en
expliquant la manoeuvre on le comprend
les blancs pourrait bien lui faire
doubler un pion en prenant leur fougue
et 6 avec votre fouet trois oui c'est
l'art si on pourrait oui entreprendre en
b si c'est peut-être il pourrait
reprendre du qui y en a mais cela
mettrait en jeu la torah 8 mai ça
libérerait voilà la torah 8 d'ailleurs
absurde du lait est un pion doublé
lorsqu'il est lié avec d'autres n'est
point désavantageux oui alors
effectivement les pions doublé c'est pas
toujours une faiblesse il est comme il
le dit là s'il est bien lié avec les
autres s'y sont pas isolés ses pions
doublé ça peut être c'est avantageux en
défense tant qu'ils bougent pas ils sont
très forts en défense
après si on est obligé de les bouger en
général ça pose ça pose des problèmes
parce que c'est pas très mobile je fais
néanmoins avec ce coup ne variantes en
faisant prendre le fou étroit avec le
fouloir donc les aussi les noirs
auraient dû prendre trois ici et il vous
propose une variante on retiendra pas
tout on sait faire la partie principale
mais vous avez une variante ici dans le
livre donc après la partie vous aurez
une variante ici 12 fouet trois fous
prendre 3 avec les noirs et non pas faux
si ce donc là il nous fait cas des f4
fille dort donc il y part à noter qu'ils
jouent pas et kateri siens alors qu'il
avait dit qu' il allait vouloir quand
même s'assurer du pion du pion aux 5
il nous dit le coeur saigne n'étant pas
encore en danger
le cavalier attaque immédiatement le fou
si ce temps qu'il se retire ou bien sûr
pour le prendre
donc il a bien notion ici de pouvoir
prendre le fou même si on ne protège
avec l'idée d'avoir la paire de fou il
le dit que les fous sont supérieurs aux
cavaliers aussi on sait les géants
gênants comme avantage c'est pas non
plus décisif mais c'est quand même ça
peut être un thème donc dans le set des
noirs joues la dame en 7 et maintenant
les bleus en profitent par faut prendre
des six qui va doubler les pions quand
même et il nous dit pourquoi ici il est
toujours dangereux de laisser le foie de
verse sur la diagonale qui attaquent le
pion à f2 wallace a raison ça résonne
c'est pas tellement de redoubler les
pions c'est pour éliminer un fou qui
quand même effectivement fait une
pression sur f2 peut soutenir plus tard
aussi une poussée csn des 4
préparez donc ils préfèrent éliminé se
font donc il est toujours dangereux de
laisser le fois de versions hd bonal qui
attaquent le pion à f2 et lorsque vous
ne pouvez pas fermer cette diagonale
avec votre pion des il faut lui opposer
votre fou c'est ce qu'ont fait les
blancs là maintenant il ya plus de pions
des qui s'opposent au fond des six et
bien c'est le foot roy qui a servi de
bouclier en fait et le feu trois
maintenant même carrément prend le fou
et 6 il faut lui opposer votre fou au
lieu de tout autre pièce si c'est
possible s'est mis à bien sûr de poser
un fou par rapport à un fou sur la
diagonale à cette f 2 puisque si on met
un cavalier ou un pion on n'a pas le
choix de prendre le foie de verse alors
qu'avec en opposant avec notre fou et
bien comme comme ici on peut même
carrément éliminé cette pièce menaçante
donc apprendre et 6 pour les noirs et
maintenant enfin petit roquet alors
notez que le rock est un coût qui n'est
pas forcément encore universel à
l'époque de philidor il ce taudis et des
endroits en espagne notamment
on joue pas l'europe parce que pour wii
lopez ya pas de rock en 1761 n'y a pas
d'europe là on est en 1749 puisque on
est en 1777 pour le livre mais cette
partie était déjà commenté en 1749
donc on est à peine deux cents ans plus
tard voilà donc les règles sont loin
d'être universelle encore en europe
il y aura même une remarque de philidor
à la fin du livre sur le fait qu en
angleterre le pat gagne la partie
voilà donc même si les règles sont quand
même beaucoup plus établies parce qu'il
fait pas mention de beaucoup
d'exceptions il ya quand même encore des
disparités assez notable un petit aparté
l'homme donc petit rock
alors il me dit les blancs rock de ce
côté pour soutenir d'autant mieux leurs
pions f qu'ils avanceront de deux cases
au moment où le pion aux 5 sera attaqué
donc en prévision de f4
c'est bien d'avoir fait l'europe puisque
la tour est en f1
on soutient bien le pian f16 qui en
général
là aussi l'idée du rock c'est aussi de
pouvoir pousser le pion f quand
l'occasion se présente que ce soit côté
blanc un côté noir d'ailleurs il ya
plein d'idées au rock notamment celle là
donc ici que les dix-sept normal les
nords finissent leur développement et
enfin il se décide à faire cavaler prend
le 6 d'emprunt de 6 et autres avis
qu'est-ce qui va jouer maintenant voilà
f4 ça y est ils l'avaient dit qu'ils
devaient le faire il le fait maintenant
les noirs lient leur tour qu'avait
laissé cette est tout simplement tour a
eu 1 et enfin g6 alors on essaie de
bloquer l'avancée du tueur il nous le
dit les noirs sont forcés de pousser ses
pions pour empêcher que leur versait en
avance sur leur dame le pion f
oui la façon de le dire le train spécial
le pour éviter que l'adversaire n'avance
sur leur dame le pion effectivement si
on joue à 100 on attaquera la dame en
même temps à noter que la case il
s'inquiétait aussi protégé par le foot
est roi
donc on n'aurait pas pu reprendre en
scène par la toile ce qui donnerait aux
blancs donc si on pouvait jouer cent ce
qui donnerait aux blancs deux pions de
front sur le terrain'' effectivement ça
serait très dangereux d'avoir 5e 5 donc
j'ai si c'était quasiment il était
obligatoire comme il le dit h3 alors
pourquoi je crois il me dit ce qu'ils
ont et jouer pour pouvoir pousser le
plonger évident puisque les noirs enjoué
g6 pour empêcher f5 mais vu qu'on peut
jouer h3 avec l'idée g4 et enfin je
crois quand même cinq et on voit mal
comment les membres peuvent s'opposer à
ça donc d4 pour les noirs russie attaque
centrale sur le cavaliers cavalières 4h
6 alors les noirs jouent ce pion pour
empêcher le cavalier d'entrer dans leur
jeu évidemment c'est pour contrôler la
casse g5 on empêche le cavalier blanc
devenir encore plus avant dans le
ternois
les morts se compteront michel carrier
d'entrer dans le jeu et de faire
déplacer la dame
ce qui donnerait à l'instant même le
champ libre aux pions 1,5 puis si on
pouvait y en avait plus joué cavalier g5
avec les blancs la dame bouge et ensuite
aux 6,7 et puis ça devient pénible voire
même en gagnant 6 b3 et la b5 alors b5
ça empêche des manoeuvres aussi comme
fou ces quatre moyens on a joué b3 en
menacé quand même 2 ou 2,5 logicien on
aurait pu contrer par khaled et 5
mais c'est quand même le pion des quatre
auraient été aurait été perdue donc b5
c'est pour empêcher ici fous ces quatre
donc h trois des quatre cas vers 4h 6 b3
b5 voilà donc et la maintenance et leur
g4 les nord continue par calais des cinq
qui est un bon coup sûr bon ça attaque
f4 et ça attaque ou si la case 3 est là
simplement cavaliers g3 alors qu'à les
j3 sans doute parce que la tour comme ça
contrôler le pion à eux cinq passes qui
lance on avait joué le signe trop tôt le
pion aux cinq était en prise mais
maintenant on pousse on attaque la dame
prise prise la dame est attaqué c'est
bien défendus par le fou le cavalier à
tour et si on prend le piocelle
évidemment on perdait la dame en voilà
donc cavalier 3 les blancs jouent ce
cavalier pour pousser ensuite le plan f
ça s'est fini d'or ans pour moi qui
alors se trouve soutenu par trois pièces
là pour le fougueux cavaliers donc ici
les noirs joue cavalier 3 donc c'est un
bon coup puisque sa coupe la défense du
plan orsec par la tour e
donc on bloque la poussée f scène par ce
coup là puisqu'en cas de f5 on perd le
pion le e5 les merlus calais pour couper
la communication entre les pièces
blanches fille dort et rompre leurs
pions ce qu'il ferait sûrement en avant
sur le pion
6 oui les noirs auraient envie
maintenant de jouer g5 un g6 anges et
celles qui veulent avancer leurs pions
parce que s'ils arrivent à jouer g5
si les blancs tous on prend le point 5
et si on prend g5 comprend aussi le pion
aux cinq et on a complètement cassé le
ses fameuses pions blancs très fort 5 et
f4 qu'il ne rêve que d'une chose c'est
d'avancer
donc les nord jusqu'à valait beau coupé
la communication entre les pièces
blanches et rompre leurs pions ce qu'il
ferait sûrement en avance sur le budget
6 mai en sacrifiant leur tour les blancs
reviennent à leurs desseins alors
qu'est-ce qui pourquoi une milice a et b
oui parce que le coup fumant des blancs
c'est tout reprend voilà il donne la
qualité et oui parce que c'est vrai
qu'en prenant en donnant la qualité bon
d'abord il récupère un pion pour un
cavalier
il récupère le contrôle de la case cinq
éléments ne peuvent plus s'opposer
enfin vous avec difficulté maintenant
pousser f scène qui devient très forte
donc en faudra quand même peut faire
attention parce qu'il ya quand même
cavalier 17 et là encore la dame si ce
qu'ils attaquent le 5 mai sa garde tout
le potentiel d'attac des blancs par fo
faut y aller il faut le faire ce
sacrifice de qualité quand même des
prendre 3 d'emprunt 3 est maintenant
plus il ya tout reprendre
donc là fallait quand même des calculs
et hélas tout simplement regarder une
philidor continue son idée
toulon quand il vous dit que son art
c'est de bien jouer les pions c'est bien
ça c'est à dire que la voyait comme une
surprotège le pion aux cinq et il veut
pousser f5
on doit voir assez vite ici que les
pions e5 et f5 bien avancer comme ça
sont une menace terrible sur le roi noir
et sur le centre noir ils vont pousser
pousser menacé de faire dame assez vite
donc to run tout simplement on
surprotège de 5 bien qu'on ait donné une
qualité voyage est la position blanche
est écrasante tourner les blancs jouent
cette tour pour soutenir le pion de 5
qui resterait en prise lors de la
poussée du crif 85
ce que je dis
mais la cdu philidor donc d'emprunt
trois tours prend 1,2 saverdun prend b3
de mon père encore le père mais trois on
va pas falloir faut pas traîner
maintenant parce qu'on a quand même si
trois pions passé même si c'était doublé
c'est pas grave c'est comme dangereux il
faut que l'attak maintenant l'emportent
et là tout simplement regarder up 24 et
dames en 2004 menace
matt hand couvre 6 et aux blancs de
jouer on a d'un projet six échecs
ensuite dans cette même veine damas sept
minarets nos prononcer le 24 et l'a donc
les noirs verts reviennent vite vite il
faut vite aller défendre rapidement
maintenant qu'on a gobé le pion mais du
coup on a perdu du temps avec les noirs
on a été peut-être un peu gourmand aller
chercher les pions comme ça si aux
blancs de jouer et la poussière 5 mais
non ne peut pas être évité f5 qui on
prend 25 puis on prend 25 voiliers
concept très fort et l'étonnant les
noirs jouent ici dans le d5 la dame
propose les changes pour rentrer pour
casser si vous voulez rompre utilise
beaucoup le mot rendront voulu garder ce
dossier c'est original pour rendre le
projet du mat par le fou de la dame
adverse
évidemment ici n'est change parce que si
la dame va ailleurs on pourrait jouer f6
menace matin et ça va être extrêmement
difficile donc il essaie dé changer la
pièce d'attac des blancs haïtien est
belle et blanc vont simplement prendre
en fait pas problème conflit dont il
prend prise prise il reste avec deux
pions en notre effort ont regardé et
maintenant tout simplement même il prend
b5
voilà alors l'idée de prendre le pion b5
ces bombes est sûre ça prend un pion
mais ça déstabilise ce cavalier
maintenant nouvelle cavaliers parce que
là si on allait jouer aussi ce trop tôt
sans doute le cavaliere aurait pu
protégez vous prendre d'essai dont qui
joue qu'à bâle et b6 est maintenant
égale il peut pas venir en effet 6 en
cadeau ainsi s'il n'y a pas de il peut
pas parvenir les mêmes y joue ici
ercis d'où l'autre pions on va observer
que lorsqu'on a un fou sur place blanche
ah oui voilà ça c'est un conseil
important
on doit observer que lorsqu'on a un fou
socas blanche ce qui est le cas des
blancs donc il faut ranger ses pions sur
les cases noires alors surtout alors
quand on est à l'attack ou si c'est un
fou de cases noires il faut les ranger
sur cases blanches white man d'accord
parce qu'alors le fou empêche les pièces
adverse de se porter entre les pions le
fou contrôler les cases blanches entre
les pions au 5 et 6 r les cases aussi
7,7 f5 et 17 peuvent être attaquées par
le fou cette règle comme indispensable
dans les cas où on a des pions passer
cette règle et comme attention c'est des
conseils précieux qui nous dit l'un
c'est pas n'importe quoi
il le redira pâtit fois donc un chèque
chaque conseil et précis parfois il vous
dit bon là on met les pions sur noir
alors que le fou voir la première partie
je vais pas me répéter à les réviser
quoi donc cette règle comme
indispensable dans les cas on aller pour
passer dans le cas de la défense allait
contraire si on était en défense pour
faire le contraire il faut alors que les
pions soit placé sur la couleur du fou
comme ça dépend si vous estimez vous
êtes en attaque qu'en défense d'accord
en attaque il faut contrôler un maximum
de cases dont vous mettez les pions sur
la couleur opposé de celui de votre fou
il a gagné une partie cet après midi je
sens et si vous êtes en défense celle
inverse
bien sûr il faut que le fonds puisse
contrôler les pions
défendant ses pions d'accord ça c'est un
principe qui devrait quasiment tout le
temps ça et c'est fini dort encore une
fois le premier qui explique dans
l'histoire du jeu personne avant lui il
a expliqué sa maintenant le scellant
quand on atteint un certain niveau c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait on n'y pense
même plus au bout de mon en course et ça
devient naturel mais vous devez le voir
visuellement les pions contre les cases
noires le fou le gaz blanche
c'est bon pour l'attack d'accord ici les
noirs jour tour b2i laisser un peu de
déstabiliser le fou fou des 3 et 3 f 7
maintenant four f5
voyez comme ce fourreau regardez
maintenant contre le 6 alors faut faire
attention pour l'instant le plus réussi
cette attaque et on pourrait pour le
défendre peut-être plus tard par un
cavalier h5 et dans ce cas là aussi je
peux pas être empêché et le roi est
obligé de reculer et on voit bien que
ces deux pions sont très proches de fer
dames 1 ça devient extrêmement dangereux
donc tourbe et de détroit bref cette
fois une 5
voici un exemple de la note donc
précédente à notre ci dessus si votre
fouetter sur quatre mois le roi reverse
pourrait se placer entre les pions leroy
à leers pour aller en russie ce bail
peut pas me presser donc si les noirs
jouent qu'elle et ses 4 et maintenant
donc à la chaîne voilà donc il contrôle
et 6 l'idée c'est qu'ils défense pions
pourquoi parce qu'il veut jouer eux six
échecs et le roi ne pourra pas prendre
le pion donc sera obligé de reculer et
on a un garde nos deux pions très fort
il faut surtout pas les données scipion
enfin si vous ferez données contre les
deux tours si on peut les échanger
contre de tout on va le faire mais mais
sinon on les garde ses sélections qui
vont faire la différence
donc cavalier h5 ici les noirs font un
échec en g8 très bien et simplement les
blancs couvre avec fuji 4 ce qui permet
de toujours contrôler la case de 600 et
bien ça gêne pas le fait qu'on court ici
n'empêche pas le contrôle cavale et des
deux jeux 6 échecs ça commence à sentir
le roussi roi g6 et maintenant on nous
dit un petit commentaire ici lobo
pouvant se retirer sur la case des
fuites venant elle aurait pu aussi jouer
trois fuites nous en ferons une variante
on la verra pas mais sachez qu'elle
existe la boucane sur ses analyses il ya
aussi grand f 8 qui est possible donc là
les blancs choisissent elles 7 alors
l'attention menace pions 30 tours dale
échec non plus donc touré fuite est
quasiment enfoncé et là maintenant
cavalier d444 parlons échec 3 g 7
quand je dis cavaliers quatre noms
finidori sine die le cavalier va sur la
4e case du fou du roi
y'a pas de coordonnées sur l'échiquier
une cavale il faudra se rappeler où est
le fou du roi
c'est quoi la place du fou du roi c'est
la case f1 la quatrième un deux trois
quatre mois au mercato
non mais ça parce que ça paraît facile à
la lecture mais au déchiffrage je peux
vous assurer que parfois on s'y perd on
sait plus où on en est donc alors
cavalière quatre échecs 3g 7 est
maintenant regarder très joli feuillage
5 précis jusqu'au bout ils contrôlaient
vii parce qu'il veut même pas que sur
sept les noirs mais prennent le pion à
vii avec le roi par exemple comme ça on
aurait 2 il aurait donné la tour
les deux pions et or encore du travail à
faire en aurait qu'une pièce davance
avait juste un pion donc si l'option
disparaît je suis même pas sûr ça gagne
donc il a quand même intérêt il faut
quand même qu'ils gardent son matériel
donc il est précis jusque loin voilà x 5
est maintenant surtout noirs les blancs
poussent leurs pions un set et ensuite
formidable en 1 8
on prendra même pas la tour en fera sans
doute dame directeur de cette menace
dames en 1 8
voilà ici la partie s'arrête partie de
première partie fils d'or et commencent
toutes les variantes qui ont été cités
dans le texte mais de tout un tas de
variantes à voir on aurait pu les voir
on peut les voir bien sûr pendant la
partie
on l'a fait une lecture un peu un peu
linéaire voilà le style de fille dort
voyez ne cherche pas il vous montre pas
des parties parfaites
il vous montre des parties où il ya
volontairement des erreurs mais vous
explique pourquoi c'est des erreurs et
comment on fait pour en profiter et dans
cette partie on voit bien comment il a
maîtrisé à la fois la notion de chaîne
de pions la notion de centre le fait de
supporter ses pions de bien les tenir
d'éviter qu'on se l'est face cas c'est
qu'on est des pions isolé essaie de les
regarder groupés et enfin de bien les
jouer au bon moment en contrôlant toutes
les cases pour avancer le fait que les
pions sont sur la couleur opposée du fou
et c'est cette partie
rien qu'à prendre cette partie les
conseils qu'il ya dedans vous gagner 150
points elo facile d'un coup non mais
c'est vrai service dans le si vous avez
à mettre en pratique tout ce qui l'a mis
là
vous imaginez c'est quand même c'est pas
facile à mettre en pratique ce qu'il a
dit là c'est facile à lire après faut
bien comprendre et arriver à le jouer
sur l'échiquier
c'est très précieux voilà donc on va
maintenant si vous voulez bien regarder
une des finales de philidor on l'a aussi
voir comment ils nous expliquent la
partie finale qui pour moi est peut-être
la partie
les deux parties sont aussi importants
du club voilà on peut pas séparer la
partie des finales de la partie de la
partie donc parti commenté
donc quand je vous ai dit viens donc
environ 13 parties jugées pas le chiffre
exact en tête mais c'est 13 au 14
parties commentées est pareil à peu près
13 14 finales et toutes les finales de
bazin alors est-ce que je vous montre
alors je vais vous montrer la position
de philidor commentée par fille dort de
touré pions contre tous d'accord parce
que c'est la plus fréquente et c'est
sans doute celle qui l'a qui est restée
célèbre puisque on l'appelle toujours
comme ça même si donc il existe aussi la
pression de philidor de tours est fou
contre pour hors jeu chaque la page
touré pions contre tours
voilà 221 voilà donc j'y suis pour une
pub de retour donc on va mettre la
position up parfois me demande quelle
est celle que j'utilise là en fait c'est
le logiciel libre qui s'appelle une site
seed et ses idées sid festive et voilà
vous trouvez vous pouvez le télécharger
sur internet via bruxelles diront
s'avère que le code le code source est
disponible donc l'informaticien peuvent
le modifier pour l'améliorer externe
alors bis défi qui ça c'est fait un
taurillon contre eux
obama sans doute à paris il n'y a pas
énormément de coups dans ces finales
qu'on pourra regarder peut-être une ou
deux variantes est ici voilà et il ya
donc un pion la position cruciale
c'est aux blancs de jouer très bien
alors j'ai une petite note ici je vais
vous la lire donc cette position
typiques là ici la voilà cette cette
position avec la méthode détaillée par
philidor constituent la très fameuse
position de philidor qui étaient
essentielles à connaître en finale elle
arrive enfin ces finales corruption
contre contre tour arrive assez souvent
il est très bon très important de l'est
de les connaître donc ici une scène qui
propose au premier coup et la tour b 6
alors écoutez bien associer sans celle
là tous les conseils sont un très
important en conservant cette traverse
on appelle travers son échec les lignes
horizontales donc latraverse ici c'est
la sixième rang jean ziegler et c'est
toujours d'actualité ce terme donc on le
dit traverse et sinon dicolo mais on y
colonnes à claude bekolo seewer
latraverse numéro 6 ou la 6e travers son
deuxième rangée en conservant cette
traverse avec leur tour donc là pour
reste ici sur cette traverse les noirs
empêche de draps blancs d'avancé oui ça
empêche effectivement l'europe pas bougé
une manip a faim il peut pas aller vers
leurs membres
et s'il quitter cette traverse avant que
les blancs des pousser leurs pions
si les voir quitter cette traverse avant
que les blancs et pousser leurs pions il
perdrait la partie attention non mais
c'est essentiel c'est l'air de rien mais
si vous avez pas compris ce point là
c'est fait c'est foutu alors on va avoir
des exemples comme vous le verrez dans
une variante donc elle n'a rien que les
noirs quitte la 6e d'accord alors
peut-être commencer par la variante
on va alors plutôt que tomber 6 à béton
jour tourner alors 2d noël et blanc ici
jouent à m6 qui profite du fait que la
peau en a laissé arras est le roi sur la
sixième
bonjour pour les u6 si les blancs
avaient joué la voie en face du roi
adverse
si les blancs ne jamais jouer le roi en
os 6 d'accord l'énorme bulle se remettre
dans la position nul ils auraient pu
refaire échec avec la tour sur la
sixième roi serait revenu et puis
finalement ce serait très vite il ne se
serait rien passé d'accord en donnant un
chèque avec les retours alors ici c'est
pas le cas ils sont venus en m-67 qui
fait que si on vient à six il va se
passer quoi à votre avis on va pousser
le pian et c'est quoi le problème
et voilà on est menacée de maths
donc l'europe va devoir partir donc s'il
part il va pouvoir laisser le champ
libre aux pions c'est bien le problème
c'est tout le problème c'est que le roi
il faut aussi regarder le roi devant le
pion pour l'empêcher d'avancer il faut
que la tourette dassin faut pas donc
permettre des menaces comme ceux de ce
type là donc tour à un roi m6 très bien
et maintenant donc les noirs tente quand
même tout va fut un échec
alors ils disent si les noirs avaient
joué les chèques en a six les blancs ont
découvert cet échec avec leurs pions
qu'ils auraient joué effectivement des 5
et 6 au lieu de ce coup il avait joué le
roy on débite aussi aussi il aurait pu
aussi jouer le roi en des 8
il aurait fallu alors pour les blancs
bonnets chèque avec leur tour a fallu
jouer tout de suite échec et ensuite
avancer leurs droits en poussette et
ensuite il aurait eu droit dedans le
pion par souvent on travaille pour
gagner ces finales là il faut que le roi
et deux dans le cube il faut que le roi
un peu comme dans la fina le roi epyon
contre roy c'est quasiment tout le temps
le cas d'ailleurs
finale 2 pièces quand il ya un pion
comme ça mais croit faut souvent que le
roi prépare le passage
si on veut gagner de prévention faut pas
pousser le pian tout seul faut que le
roi soit oeuvres sinon on n'arrive pas
le cas où tout seul et il se fait blogo
d'un uci simon cc joly dit voilà c'est
donc ici il ya eu donc tout reste un don
mais de l'envoi aux 6 et là c'est quoi
le problème
c'est matt alors imaginez qu'on ne
couvre pas imaginer qu'on couvre par
paroisse et fuite là-haut par touré
suite pardon si on couvrait pas retombée
simitis pasqua et voilà il y aurait
toujours à 7 qui menacent mate aussi ou
alors de gagner le tour mais on ne peut
rien faire
oui c'est sûr on peut aussi arriver à
faire nul le oui alors mais le problème
après c'est que oui alors il n'y a pas
tous les coups il peut y avoir
effectivement des petits 0 m'en fais ça
montre quand même que la possibilité de
galles mais on va pas jusque là parce
que moi j'ai repris le manuel g pas
faire une nouvelle théorie ont montré
toutes les astuces mais tu as raison
revue c'est vrai tout à fait
si on joue très précis mais c'est encore
il donc il faut aller plus loin après on
peut arriver a effectivement à fermeture
raison c'est juste mais c'est fini d'or
attention donc oui donc c'est juste que
c'est lui mais on est on est sur
internet plus élevés là quand on entre
les pièges quand même de cette finale
ici mais tu as raison c'est vrai c'est
juste donc ici roi aux 6 3 et 8 les
noirs où le roi en fuite est là donc ils
nous proposent tourache huit échecs
relais 7 est maintenant tours 8
voilà avec une opposition devient très
difficile à défendre pour les noirs ceci
dit sur une très bonne défense comme tu
mènes le dire en fait on peut toujours
encore arrive à faire mieux ici
d'accord donc il continue quand même
vous montrer comment on peut gagner
il y a
très précis à connaître qui permet
encore d'assurer là nul mais très peu de
joueurs savent le jouer parfaitement
voilà mais c'est quand même une suite
ici qui ne permet pas au noir d'assurer
là nul face il ya encore des choses
théorie de la connaître parfaitement ici
donc on a préparé le terrain on a
empêché le roi noir d'être devant le
pion et on a tous encore des chances de
gain qui sont qui sont nets alors il
vous montre le gain possible et c'est
vrai que depuis dans les années mais ces
récents c'est au 20e siècle on a réussi
une méthode pour vraiment sur un coup
sûr une méthode encore plus précis
arrivée annulé ici encore avec enora
d'accord on va revenir par l'imposition
de fielder ou l'annuler encore est quand
même plus simple pour les noirs ici
chances de gain pour les blancs encore
encore très forte
d'accord on revient maintenant sur la
partie au début
ici donc simplement quitte pas la
sixième voilà on joue tour b 6
maintenant retour à cette tendance et 6
et il dit
les hommes doivent quitter cette
traverse avec la tourner court moment où
les blancs passeront leurs pions voilà
si vous attendez que le pion bougez vous
allez voir après c'est très simple
d'annuler pas du tout qu'on à l'autre
variante où ça devient extrêmement
compliqué et la plupart des joueurs
perdent 1 il ya peu les grands maîtres
car elle va jouer là la position
théorique vraiment on arrive à sauver
les meubles
donc ici donc c'est 6 ie6 et c'est
l'heure le pion à pousser le problème
d'avoir poussé le pion maintenant c'est
que le droit peut plus venir devant le
pion voyez donc le roi noir ont regardé
ici empêchera le râble hante toujours de
manière donne
donc il pourra pas se cacher des échecs
donc c'est l'heure de faire des échecs
attention à ce qu'on fait ici pas même
si vous faites tous ces cinq échecs
c'est quoi le problème
le roi bien m6 et alors il ya menace de
maths alors vous pouvez pas pareil parce
que si vous jouez pour ces huit plateaux
repas denis côté h7 est encore il ya
menace de maths et voilà vous perdez la
tour d'autres insistent maintenant c'est
l'heure pour la tour devenir anciens et
c'est fini parce qu'on va harceler le
roi et si on couvre imaginer qu'on
arrive à couvrir avec la tombe blanche
simplement en échange
et vous savez que la finale roi epyon
d'entre eux roi ici et nulle
alors si vous en êtes pas sûrs et sains
a sans doute parmi vous qui n'êtes pas
ce qu'ils savaient pas forcément annulé
au roi étions contre eux roi mais sachez
que la méthode pour annuler roi et 3
allée dans le bouquin aussi d'accord non
mais voilà c'est pour ça que quand vous
connaître une finale il faut s'y
connaître les autres l incident
c'est une chaîne donc c'est quand même
bien expliqué et l'autre méthode vous
assure pas une nulle de tranquillement
d'accord alors que celle là ces 6
derniers donc inversement si vous allez
les blancs avec un problème énorme part
si vous avez une finale tout rupture
contre tours sachez que ça se sachant
que cette position finul il faut
l'éviter
donc il faut couper loin en fait c'est
ça la technique faut couper le roi des
ronces pour l'empêcher de venir de voir
le pion à tout prix et plus les loin
plus vous arrivez à l'éloigner plus la
finale sera facilement gagnable
ceci dit attention à la méthode de gains
elle n'est pas non plus
simple il ya une petite méthode on se
cacher avec la tour bon je vous passe
tous les détails je vais pas vous faire
la théorie n'est pas le butin là je vous
demande quand même ce que le dividende
je ferai un autre court plus tard
peut-être là-dessus mais il ya des
joueurs qui sont mieux meilleur comment
pour expliquer ces subtilités l'a donc
bah voila je vous ai fait un parti
commenté de philidor espuma expliquer ce
livre je vous ai fait maintenant une
finale alors philidor né en 1726 il
meurt en 1795 et on a estimé qu' il
avait envie presque séance entendent
avance sur les sur ses contemporains et
que c'est qu'à partir de stone town on
peut dire que les joueurs ont commencé à
jouer mieux que lui quoi voilà donc il
était carrière comme une grosse trop
s'avancer on peut il n'a pas eu de rival
et on peut on peut il ya aucun rival
stamm a été sans doute le match contre
ça mais c'est sans doute le match de
philidor le plus le plus connu et il ya
quand même mis 7 à 3 et en plus il était
encore très jeune et donc plus tard il
ya ilahi la you can opposant il n'a
jamais été en danger toute sa carrière
de joueur d'échecs
il a fini sa carrière au club de l'ombre
on était à la révolution française donc
on l'accusé d'être un immigré menace de
mort ce n'est pas un noble
il s'en est défendu d'être un immigré
lors de la révolution et surtout c'était
le club de londres lui permettait de
vivre puisque le paient pour aller jouer
aux échecs alors qu'il avait plu son
cachet de musiciens puisqu'il était
musicien du roi et que le roi bombay
savait que le rendant 89 il lui arrivait
des bricoleurs
forcément la rentrée de philidor est
passé à la trappe avec bah merci de
m'avoir suivi
donc si vous avez des questions ou des
approfondissements c'est maintenant
prenez un micro oui alors venez prendre
le micro
alors combien d'éditions alors à ma
connaissance il ya là quelque chose
comme entre 70 et 80 alors à la au
détail près que toutes ces éditions date
donc son 18e
évidemment pour les premières soit du
19e siècle mais depuis le 20e siècle à
ma connaissance il n'a pas eu il ya
aucune édition xxème siècle en fait il
ya une édition en 1988 mais qui est pas
une reddition c'est un fac similé donc
en fac similé ça veut dire quoi c'est
une photocopie enfin donc c'est une
photocopie d'une édition du jean de
vienne dont il y avait rien de nouveau
1988 voilà mais si j'ai une copine
donc vous allez chercher la copie de
l'original vous pouvez avoir des copies
sur le net aujourd'hui dans il ya des
projets de numérisation des
bibliothèques il ya beaucoup de livres
disponibles sous cette forme-là donc
vous aurez un original c'est encore
mieux quoi donc ya pas eu de nouvelle
édition ce que j'appelle une nouvelle
édition c'est qu'il ya eu un travail
supplémentaire de fait il ya eu un âge
où il ya eu une transformation de
de la matière originale pour en faire
quelque chose de moderniser quoi donc
moi ce que j'ai rajouté c'est d'abord
jérôme bellay de préface de 17 149 10
717 crois que je suis pas sûr que s'il
était fait ailleurs j'ai tout alger
toumi en notation algébrique il ya
quelques il ya des livres de philidor
qui ont été mis en oeuvre à givry ça
existe mais c'est pas tout les éditions
sont des 77 qui existe j'ai pas il ya
peut-être une dizaine pas plus et j'ai
mis un échiquier tous les quatre coups
aussi ça je pense que c'est assez unique
voilà et puis j'ai rajouté j'ai rajouté
une préface avait des informations il ya
aussi quelque chose comme une
cinquantaine une soixantaine de notes de
bas de page avec des informations
supplémentaires notamment sur tous les
joueurs qui cite parce qu'il va citer je
voulais dit tout à l'heure un petit peu
ici depuis lingam et site bertin is it
dont le pied trop car gras qui sont des
des joueurs aussi et donc j'ai fait des
petites recherches et j'ai eu quand même
des informations sur ses joueurs dans
dans le livre alors là on ne parle pas
de rue lopez du tout alors voilà donc ça
c'est important ça reste un mystère
façon le livre 2010 henri lopes pour moi
est un mystère c'est à dire que c'est à
la fois pour moi c'est une grande
découverte en fait je ne connaissais pas
du tout son livre il ya encore de ça je
dirais trois ans donc j'ai découvert ça
existait et je me suis dit faut que je
le lise
bon j'ai cherché les éditions j'ai
cherché des informations et j'en
trouvais pas à part le livre lui-même à
part des des copies du livre des fac
similés donc des photocopies des
bibliothèques qui ont gardé des
originaux il y en a très très peu il ya
très peu d'originaux dans le monde et
c'est par prix alors c'est à la fois
enfin c'est un mystère mais j'ai quand
même des bribes de réponses pourquoi ils
en parlent pas non plus alors il n'en
parle pas quand il dit qu' il peut y
avoir un lien entre le jeu d'échecs
moderne
enfin tout cas le jeu d'échecs du xviiie
et le latron coulis romain à ma
connaissance mais bon j'ai pas lu assez
pour savoir mais celui qui parle de ce
lien à 6 rue lopez donc s'il n'a
peut-être pas lui mais cette
informations viennent y livre de rio
pèse donc le mystère vient peut-être du
fait que justement les règles de rue
lopez sont pas du tout les mêmes puisque
pour u lopez le roi sorte de deux cases
il n'y a pas de rock et rue lopez met en
avant la prise en passant alors que les
italiens ne joue pas bon fille dort pour
lui la présentation ça pose pas de
questions il ya la prise en passant il
fait quand même quelques remarques au
début du philidor sur le fait que les
allemands se permettent je suis plus
comme indice infondées retrouver le
terme mais c'est amusant mais se
permettent à tort c'est un peu n'importe
quoi on y voit là de jouer deux pions à
la fois à l'époque les allemandes après
philidor à l'époque les allemands encore
jouer un e3 détroit pour équilibrer le
fait qu'on puisse aussi joué le pion de
deux cases
il dit que c'est ça va contre le sens du
jeu c'est n'importe quoi c'est amusant
de voir ça parce que oui lopez dit la
même chose des italiens sur le rock
c'est à dire qu'on voit que dans la
construction des règles du jeu si on lit
ses auteurs et qu'on fait attention
c'est eux qui ont impulsé le fait qu'on
a qu'on garde certaines ruelles et quand
on en enlève d'autres c'est eux qui ont
leur avis et qu'on a suivi
voilà donc c'est eux qui ont construit
genève c'est pas c'est pas le comité qui
s'est réuni quelque part non c'est les
grands joueurs de leur temps qui déjà
accepté sans doute de jouer avec les
règles qu'on leur propose et qui pouvait
être variés et qui ont retenu celle
qu'ils estimaient les plus les plus
conformes à l'esprit du jeu et en france
on trouve encore balawi
oui alors il faudrait que je retrouve ce
passage à oui oui oui ah oui je vais
essayer de vous retrouver le passage où
il part de ça parce que c'est marrant
c'est marrant oui oui voila voila
écoutez bien oui c'est lors d'un goûter
bien mérité en plusieurs endroits du
allemagne on a défiguré ce jeu 1-2 le
reconnaître que par la forme de
l'échiquier les pièces premièrement on
fait jouer deux coups de suite on
commence à la partie cette méthode
apparaît d'autant plus ridicule qu'il
n'y a aucun jeu où l'on ne joue
alternativement chacun son tour
ceci dit ce sont 7 remarquer les ailes
et elle est tendancieuse parce que le
rock c'est bien de quoi le foin est ici
l'argument d'henri lopez pour refuser le
rock aussi donc si on suivait ce conseil
situerait lopez il faut absolument
écrire à la fidh et pour leur dire en ce
moment il faut changer le rock la
d'après rue lopez des filles d'or c'est
extrêmement discutables comme règle et
d'ailleurs pour rappelant les aimants
concevoir qu entre deux bons joueurs
celui qui joue le dernier et beaucoup de
chance pour gagner la partie
en second lieu on donne un pion aux
pions le droit de passer prise en donne
aux pions le droit de passer pris par
ces prix ça veut dire on donne aux pions
le fait de pouvoir jouer de deux cases
en évitant la prise en passant en
allemagne c'est exactement la méthode
d'ailleurs qui avait qui étaient
jouables en italie il n'y avait pas la
prise en passant que henry lopez avait
fortement quand même insisté pour qu'on
ait cette prise en passant c'est pas
normal que le pion comme ça puisse
s'échapper alors que l'autre a fait tout
le travail en fait à l'idée 1
le soldat est arrivée jusqu'aux francs
et l'autre fille prend un coup il
s'échappe
donc on sait qu'on lui en donne aux
pions le droit de passer prises ce qui
fort non seulement un jeu tout différent
des véritables mais il diminue de
beaucoup sa beauté parce qu'un seul pion
pourra passer au devant de deux autres
qui avaient cadré ses peines se seront
industriel industrieuse mans glissé à
trois casses de faire dame et qui se
trouveront arrêté par le roi ou par un
fou adverse tandis que ce seul pion ira
ou faire une dame où vous forcera
d'abandonner tous les votre avancée pour
venir faire la guerre à ce misérable
qu'il a aucun mérite et qui l'a rendu
aucun service dans le courant de la
partie c'est assurément tout opposé aux
maximes de la guerre le mérite seul peut
contribuer à l'avancement d'un simple
soldat
si vous lisez leur hurle quand on lit ça
bon c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
creuser qu'il faut regarder mais moi je
sens le plagiat buzzer ce passage est
très semblable à celui qu'on lit dans
leur vie lopez pour pas dire le même
coin il est dehors comme celle du
français du xviiie et que l'autre et
l'espagne du 16e on peut dire mons mais
si vous lisez
parce qu'il parle aussi de la référence
à la guerre dans ce passage là oui lopez
le fait que le pion est un tous ces
arguments sont dans le rue lopez déjà on
la selphy leader de plus lorsque le roi
rope il a le privilège de pousser en
même temps le pion de la tour ah oui en
plus en allemagne quand le roi rock ils
avaient le privilège aussi de pousser le
plan de la tour il pouvait peut-être
faire le roc est en fait joué à trois
est dans ce qu'elle joue encore deux
fois de suite selon moi tout s'est dit
fort mythe et ont été introduites par
des chicanes heures qu'ils encourent qui
pour leur avantage or on fait jouer les
gens à leur fantaisie c'est bien ça moi
j'aime bien quand ça casse un peu
ouais c'est pas mal quoi voilà donc
voyez donc vous avez quand même des
informations la préface de 49 et très
riche d'informations comme ça parfois
très attentifs un faux pas le lire comme
on lit comme ça chez pas moins de
recettes de cuisine chaque phrase est
pesée quoi il ya beaucoup d'informations
vous avez notre ont peut-être une autre
question
je crois qu'elle passages amusants sur
ce thème là ah oui oui
écoutez bien je vous fais ça pour finir
si vous voulez après vous pourrez y est
impressionnant dans sa bouche mains de
critiques il m'est impossible d'avoir
assez de complaisance pour épargner mes
compatriotes
on ne parle pas les français n'ont plus
loin qu'ils ont donnée dans une erreur
aussi grande que celle des allemands qui
sont d'autant moins pardonnable qu'il ya
parmi eux une quantité de très bons
joueurs et même des plus excellents de
l'europe
il est donc à présumer qu'ils se sont
laissés entraîner
comme j'ai fait autrefois donc mais a
coupé par une mauvaise coutume établi
selon toute apparence par quelques
ignorants qui aura été l'introducteur de
ce jeu dans le royaume
je veux persuadé que c'était un joueur
de dames qui ne sachant à peu près que
la marche les échecs s'imaginer quant à
la dame on pouvait faire autant que sur
un damier
je demande donc sain si t'es pas là mais
d'autres qui ont limité ce jeu une seule
dame de tours de chevalier etc
si cela ne fait pas un bel effet de voir
promener sur un échiquier deux pions
planté sur une même case pour marquer
une seconde dame c'est à dire que les
joueurs avaient pour habitude quand il
faisait dame de mettre deux pions sur la
case où nous pu en arriver à dame pour
si aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait en
général on mean to renversé vous savez
quand on n'a pas de dents montre et les
joueurs ici mettez deux pions bon c'est
pas non plus là c'est pas trés pas très
grave parce que c'est symbolique on peut
comprendre que c'est une dame mais quand
même il dit que c'est pas bien si cela
ne fait pas un bel effet de voir
promener sur l'échiquier deux pions
planté sur une même case pour marquer
une seconde dame sylvia une troisième
chose que j'ai vu plusieurs fois à paris
imaginons qu'une troisième dame cela
fait encore meilleure figure surtout il
est encore plus les coins
il faut traduire dans les autres à 10
heures quand est-ce que lorsque la base
du pion est à peu près aussi large que
la case qui donne contenir de oui en
plus si l'option est tro dro et
abondamment
je laisse donc jugé je laisse donc a
jugé à présent si cette méthode n'est
pas des plus ridicules et d'autant plus
blâmable qu'elle ne se pratique dans
aucun endroit où le jeu d'échecs est
connu
toutefois si malgré les remontrances les
compatriotes s'obstine à continuer dans
la même erreur je veux les exhorter
d'avoir au mans la précaution pour
éviter tout chicane de faire faire dans
un jeu d'échecs trois ou quatre dames
autant de tours chevalier et c'est pour
les placer au besoin en prévision de la
promotion conseille quand même d'avoir
dont plusieurs dames à l'avance ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui dans les tournois vous
savez qu'il est interdit à l'arrêt du
jeu aujourd'hui de remplacer le pion qui
va à dame par une toux renverser ou même
par deux pions comme il voulait faire à
l'époque etc
il faut remplacer par une dame sinon le
coût est jugé comme un coup illégal un
quart d'heure m la taux reste le tour
même s'il est renversé effectivement
donc du coup ça va poser problème aux
joueurs exactement voilà voilà pour le
libre fille dort merci de m'avoir donc
suivi